salut moi c'est sherman genoux vous
parler de mon héros il est hyper ses
lèvres
il a des tas de diplômés résout des
problèmes dans le monde il est trop fort
comme un inventaire ah oui et c'est mon
père qui est un chien littéralement je
suis un chercheur allemand est
littéralement littéraire j'ai pas
compris bien sûr que c'est un chien mais
ils sont beaucoup d'autres pertes
il m'emmène à l'école sharma s'il faut
pour aller aux toilettes lave la main
avec fierté dit j'ai besoin de sortir
il me prépare à déjeuner
pas mal plus beau des on passe du temps
ensemble ils me voient dans plein
d'endroits géniaux 20 aujourd'hui
monsieur pinault dit pas où cheikh man
quant à notre façon plutôt cool j'ai une
machine à remonter le temps
je l'ait appelé le chronomat conduire la
socam
on est allé en egypte monsieur pinault
dit oui sherman de prendre ta main bien
sûr que tu peux oh là là et l'effroi
demain monsieur peabody charbagh ce
n'est pas ma main les bras m'en tombent
et en italie
léonard de vinci pas machines volantes
ger butt
on est même tombé en pleine révolution
française je ne loupe jamais flashé
et la graine c'est géant ouais à laisse
le champ de bataille à banes affirmatif
monsieur maintenant mais mon père peut
être parfois surprotecteur sherman
goethe interdit formellement de faire la
guerre de troie
mais c'est pas juste tous mes copains
ils font la guerre de troie gâchis
messieurs peabody est plein de choses à
la fois
szczesny danseurs mixologiste musicien
et inventeur et pays ce pilote chef
savants et comédien j'ai pu prendre si
tu joue peut-être puis-je vous être de
quelques élites est très bon mais ce que
j'aime le plus chez lui maintenant on
peut acheter dans sexy mon père avant
d'y aller je veux que tu prennes ceci un
sifflet ultrasons quoi qui marchent pas
messieurs thibault il marche très bien
sherman
dreamworks présentent monsieur pivot
digues et chairman les voyages dans le
temps